Speaker 1: . I want to do a very important
follow up. When comedian Bob Saget unexpectedly,
suddenly died not long ago, I and many others
predicted there are anti-vax people who are
going to say this is because of the vaccine.
Now, of course, there was no evidence of that.
And there's no evidence vaccines are killing
people. It's important to say, but it was a very
accurate prediction, and Candace Owens was one of
the people who made that prediction, and it was
disgusting and it was irresponsible. We now have
learned the cause of death of Bob Zagat's tragic
death, and it is head trauma, per his own family,
CNN reporting. Bob Saget, who was found dead in
his Orlando, Florida, hotel room last month,
died from the result of a head trauma. Quote
The authorities have determined bob pass from head
trauma, they concluded. He hit. He accidentally
hit the back of his head on something,
thought nothing of it and went to sleep.
No drugs or alcohol were involved. Now, completely
irresponsibly, as many of you will remember,
prominent right winger Candace Owens and
others made statements like the following.
And now I mean, there was no evidence for it
at the time. Now we actually have a cause of
death. Think about how disgusting this is,
particularly if you are bob targets family.
Speaker 2: So am I a conspiracy theorist or am I
Nostradamus? The answer is neither. I'm just not
on Big Pharma's payroll and I refuse to peddle in
their lies. And so to that end, today, I'm going
to point out another truth, and it will likely be
deemed a conspiracy theory until it's not. There
are too many healthy individuals like Bob Saget,
who we know have received their vaccinations, who
are dropping dead suddenly and unexpectedly with
no further explanation. Healthy athletes, young
students in their physical prime, the majority
of the males dropping suddenly and unexpectedly
in the middle of games from heart issues.
Speaker 1: Now, as I told you at the time,
it is not that rare. I mean, you know,
statistically these things are rare,
but they happen. And I remember growing up and I
remember when the basketball player Reggie Lewis
died suddenly, and at that point there was no
hammer called anti-vaxx. So the Reggie Lewis death
was not considered a nail with which you could
hit with that anti-vaxx hammer. Now they have
this hammer and they want to use it on everything.
Speaker 2: What we know for a fact is that these
people are being mandated to take the vaccine. And
we know for a fact that these vaccines come with a
warning that they bring about myocarditis.
Speaker 1: Now, as you guys know,
there are at last check three instances of
myocarditis that have resulted in death in
the United States related to the vaccines.
And almost every instance of myocarditis
resolves quickly and without incident, and
it is in and of itself rare. And the risk of
getting myocarditis from COVID is higher than
getting it from the vaccine. But remember,
if you've got this huge hammer and
you've invested a lot of money in it,
you're going to be saying everything is a nail.
Speaker 2: The media is once again gaslighting
the public, pretending that to even take notice
of this very alarming trend is a conspiracy.
Speaker 1: Well, it is. It is completely
without evidence. And as far as Bob Saget
is now concerned, it is not the case
and it was disgusting when she said it.
It continues to be disgusting and they're not
planning on stopping. And that's the thing. You
have to be ready when they start with this stuff.
We really need to be ready to say, what evidence
do you have that that is what took place here?
And of course, she had none. And there is none.
Bob Saget tragically dying from from a head
trauma and it is. It's just gross that people like
Candace Owens are able to monetize and weaponize
this incredible disinformation. And she has a
big following. She she's well-funded and has a big
following, and a lot of people hear this stuff and
they just accept it. Let me know your thoughts.
Find me on Twitter at Packman. We'll be right back